let's start the headlines today with
some good news the United States uh Mrs
from the daily wire the United States
Women's National team has been
eliminated from the FIFA Women's World
Cup after losing in a penalty shootout
to Sweden marking the earliest exit in
history for the team Sweden beat the
United States in the round of 16
following 120 Minutes of play and a
dramatic penalty shootout in which the
video assistant referee confirmed a shot
by Sweden zelinta Lena hertig did cross
the line shocking American players and
fans who thought it was saved by the
American goalkeeper the U.S women's team
has won the tournament four times more
than any other national team and a win
this year would have marked the team's
third consecutive Championship
but that didn't happen and they lost now
um this was truly the worst defeat for
the women's team since they lost to a
group of high school boys a few years
ago actually the Swedish team may have
been comprised of high school boys at
this point and uh you know who who knows
I don't know I didn't watch the game but
we haven't gone to the best part yeah
the best part is that Megan Rapinoe the
team captain who said that she
previously she's going to retire after
the end of the season
she had a penalty kick or a free kick or
whatever it is
I again I'm not a communist I don't
watch soccer I don't know what the rules
are but it was some kind of kick at the
end and uh a chance to save the day for
her team and instead as her very last
act as a professional soccer player
here's what happened let's watch that
together
well I don't feel bad laughing first of
all because she's laughed she's laughing
at that kick that's how terrible it was
um honest to God I could do better than
that I really could I I've kicked a
soccer ball approximately zero times in
my entire life and I could do better I
really could you know I they could they
could have pulled some dude down from
the stands with a mustard stains on his
shirt and still eating a hot dog with a
hot dog in one hand and he would get off
a better kick than that
so uh really a disaster for Megan rapino
and the women's team and great to see
our country might be headed in the wrong
direction but prageru videos could help
save the future of America Prager you
makes educational pro-american content
that's been changing people's minds for
over a decade their impact is pivotal in
these times my friends at Prager you are
reaching millions of people with their
educational videos but they have a long
way to go you can help Prager you reach
thousands more people by joining Club
five for just five dollars or more per
month go to prego.com Club five now to
join your gift will ensure that prageru
has the support it needs to be here for
the Long Haul what are you waiting for
join a movement with thousands of people
and thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America you'll receive a
free Prager U bumper sticker plus an
e-book of scripts from prageru's five
minute videos when you join Club five
today that's prageru.com Club five today
now after this humiliation Megan rapino
was asked about her favorite moments as
a soccer player and that last moment
definitely was not one of them but
here's what she said
is there a memory that stands out to you
right now in this moment
oh
um
I mean probably equal pay chance
um after the final
um
and I think you know they're saying
equal pay but could have been saying a
lot of things I think this team is
always fought for so much more and uh
that's been the most rewarding part for
me of course playing in World Cups and
winning championships and doing all that
but
um you know to know that we've used our
really special talent to do something
you know that's really like changed the
world forever I think that means it most
to me and you know the players in this
locker room here
um they're just getting started and you
know to all the players that I've played
with obviously
um you know who know what it's like to
be in the grind
um that's the best part
it's an ironic response because she had
just proven why women should not have
equal pay with men in soccer but that's
that's what she cares about that's the
Highlight for her she spent her career
whining that she wants to be paid as
much as as the men and that to her is
the main takeaway from her own career
and I basically agree I think most
people do see
um
I'm happy that they lost and that she
was embarrassed and many people feel the
same Twitter was full of people gloating
about it deservedly so
but ideally it shouldn't be this right
way you know in a healthy country
Sports It's supposed to be one of those
things that unites people that you know
we all root for the for our Sports
Heroes we all root for especially if
it's a national team we should all be
rooting for that team as a national team
um and yeah maybe what happens on the
field or on the court in and of itself
doesn't matter that much but
at least this opportunity for everyone
to just sort of like be on the same side
about something as as Superfluous as
that thing might be
on the surface
but
we don't we don't have that anymore from
Sports and we don't have it from from
this because
um these are women who kneel during the
national anthem we went overseas
disrespecting their own country and flag
these are the women Megan rapid in
particular who betray not only their
country but their own sport their own
profession and the women who may come
after them when she came out and
enthusiastically endorsed letting males
compete against females
in sports
so these are partisan hacks in an
athletic costume these are ideologues in
a jersey
and they aren't even trying to represent
the United States they're representing a
very specific viewpoint
right that's that's who they're trying
to represent so they're part of the
problem they are part of the move
towards making Sports non-unifying
making it partisan and divisive which it
was never supposed to be it's supposed
to be again the opposite of that
and then the end result is this uh
unfortunate scenario where they're
supposed to be representing their
country they lose and their country is
happy about it
but it's their own fault it's their own
fault that their country mocks them when
they lose this is what they've done to
themselves hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there